But in general, uh, I, I do find taxis a little awkward.
I dunno as somebody again, who thinks about things a lot socially,
I like to think of like the perfect social situations. What's the.
What's good about them? Well, I don't understand. Okay.
Well actually talk so highly of taxis in Japan. It's good.
Because I know they'll,
they'll actually know some of them do actually try and talk to me.
None of them ever talk to me, but some of them, some of them will. Yeah.
I, I feel some of the older ones, they bust out a conversation. Someone who'd.
Also maybe learned English in college.
Or something. I've noticed taxi drivers in the countryside to me. Oh yeah.
They love talking. Yeah. In the city. It's just like, all right. It's, you're,
you're a customer. I am a taxi driver. I will not communicate in any way,
shape or form.
It's charming. Um, and in Japan,
I think one of the taxi drivers time talk to you because especially in English,
when they try and talk to you, it's like, Oh, you were,
you were putting in the work. So please focus on driving. But you know,
go ahead and.
Taxi driver I ever had was in, um, it was in Okinawa and, uh,
we were going from what constitutes a good taxi driver. Yeah.
That's a good question. I guess it was a good taxi driver drivers talk to you.
Sometimes I got to be in the right mood. Yeah, same here.
Like sometimes I'm just so, like, you know, 3:00 AM. Right.
And I'm like either drunk or just title both. And I'm stepping in,
I don't want to have a conversation with the text. Yeah, yeah. Some sometimes,
sometimes you get in a taxi driver and they ask how your day's going.
And I'm just like, [inaudible], by the way I live, here we go. Here we go.
I mean, it depends if I'm alone or with friends, I mean,
have you ever had a taxi driver who bought into a conversation between you and
friends?
Yeah. I hate that. I'm like, Whoa,
hold up in the social invitations.
None of the best right ahead. Wasn't Okinawa, because we were,
we were going to go if we were going from our hotel to this, like one, uh,
causal in Naha and it was like a 30 minute taxi ride. Um,
and the dude was like, you know, obviously an older gentleman,
but he clearly had been there his entire life. So, and he knew immediately,
he was like, Oh, foreign is you clearly,
I don't know a whole lot about this place. Huh.
And he started talking and he took us on this really scenic route.
Like all these like places, but she said, he's like,
I took you on the Sini crude, but I'll charge you for the regular. Oh,
so he was nice enough. So he was like,
actually like kind of stop the car and kind of be like, this is this. And
[inaudible] I actually had something very similar happened to me when I went to
Koshi Valley because we want it to go to the taxi drivers.
Just part-time like tourists.
I think they're just happy because they just have one,
they're happy to have tourists there because I'm pretty sure business has not
been banging this year. Um, so yeah, we, me and Sydney was on his taxi drive,
uh, on his taxi ride to get to this winery. And he's like,
let me give you a tour of the other wineries in the area as well.
Just in case you want to go. Yeah. Yeah. You want to go to it? And he, yeah.
He only charged us for the taxi rides to the one winery. But yeah,
we got a tour of like one rebounded, show me these taxi drivers. I'll never,
again, like I feel taxi drivers like that. That really only in the countryside.
Yeah. You don't really.
Get that dude in Tokyo. That miserable. Yeah. I would be to be honest, I also,
this, uh, what's the, Oh, it's in Roppongi. There's a big cemetery. Um,
I'll find it.
I'll.
Send you a picture of me down, but um,
there's this whole area right next to this giant cemetery ripe.
There's a big stretch of road. Taxi drivers, just sleep.
There are really hundreds of taxis parked. Right.
And they all park and they all just sleep and like change clothes in this area.
It's on a busy road in a really busy area, which they all just sleep there. Wow.
So bizarre. Yeah. You can do that here. You can just park your car on the,
on a busy road and just sleep like people do that. It's so weird.
You can't do that in the UK. No, I feel most countries you can't do that.
Even in the countryside. That'd be weird.
Someone would come and stop you and be like, yo, are you okay? What's up?
Have you, by the way seen, I couldn't believe this, but have you seen, uh,
those like rare taxis that you can get in Tokyo brand taxes?
I can't believe Japan has actually done this,
but they've literally turned taxis into. Gotcha. No more.
They have wait, I forgot the exact name of it,
but I think it's called like SOCRA taxis.
So you know how like in most taxis until, and this is only a Tokyo thing, uh,
but like, you know, how on taxis,
like they usually have like the signs on top of the car, like show, you know,
whether the taxi's open or whatnot. Yeah. Apparently out of,
I think like the 7,400 taxi cars in the greater Tokyo area,
there are five taxis that have like a soccer thing on top of it.
And supposedly that's like the SSR or taxis. And it's like,
what am I? Cause one of my friends, I actually got it the other day. Um,
and when you enter into the taxi, it's lot, lot nicer.
And like actually like first class of taxis and inside,
there's like a little sheet of paper that says, congratulations,
you found one of five cultural red taxis. I hate that.
I think that's so cool. Yeah. I think that's so cool. And I'm just like,
I really want to kind of go around now trying to find this mythical taxi.
This SSR maxi dude, my, my, my Gachet pool.
It's the Gacha pool of taxis now already. He's like,
Oh my every time you use like Tokyo taxi, it's just like, come on,
give me the SSR. Give me the, what is this?
Like a North point naught one or something like that. it. I'll give it a go.
Why not? Let's let's get more taxi.
Just calling a taxi after taxi his house.
And they're all just parked up either way as I see it now don't worry.
I don't need a taxi. Let me it's like, Oh. It's blue bag blue bag. Just like,
come on, give me the gold bag back. Well, I just think that's so fun.
We can call that. Like, that's just like one extra,
I guess like piece of enjoyment you can have as a tourist. Right?
Like knowing that now when you come to Japan and you go on a taxi, like you can,
you can look forward to that being like finna pull the SSR, some taxis.
It's the one reason a tourist.
You should use a taxi because God they're expensive in Japan or in Tokyo.
They get off. If you take a short journey as well,
but I've taken sometimes I've had like too much to carry.
So I've had to get like, it's like a short walk from the station to my house.
But I remember like a few times I've gotten the taxi because I had like too much
stuff to carry. They were like, Oh duh.
Okay. Oh, here. And then I said.
Yeah. And then I said like, thank you when I leave and they don't say it back.
And I'm like, wow. Okay. In Japan, that's like the biggest, you. Yeah.
Thank you. Back the audacity. That's like the equivalent of flipping the book.
Yeah.
I can realize that until.
Someone pointed out that it happened another time as well. They're like, wow.
That was really rude. I'm like, well, is he? Yeah.
He didn't say thank you back. Whatever. What? what a.
What happened was a similar situation where it's like a very short journey.
It was like an $8 journey.
And then I got out and the other person where he was like, wow,
that was so rude. I'm like, what was rude? He just drove us.
He didn't say anything. He's like, yeah. I said, thank you.
He didn't say it back. I'm like, Oh, okay. All right. Here's the.
Udacity of this piece. I'm a fit.
To get back in that car and give him a slap, you know like.
Well, like that's the thing. It's like,
it's just Tokyo taxis that are just so expensive. Because like,
if you think about it,
catching a taxi in Tokyo is a luxury because trains are just so
convenient Tokyo. Whereas the moment you're out of the greater Tokyo area,
a lot of places without a taxi you'll feel.
Yeah. It depends. I think it depends where you're going, because there's some,
if you're on the outskirts of Tokyo sometimes going,
if you're going in like an art, like a spotlight light, not quarter circle,
let's say that they don't really have trains that go like London. Right.
It's the exact same what trains go in and out and they don't go round normal.
Right. So if you want to go to the outskirts, most of the time to get like just,
you know, a 15 minute taxi drive away,
it might require you to go in all the way to central and then go out.
It's like 50 minutes. And it's like, well,
you know how much is 45 minutes of my time worth or 30 minutes.
But I think like the majority of people.
Just don't care about that. Right? Yeah. If you're like, you know, go into,
whereas in Okinawa, there's literally.
One tram line that goes for five stops and that's the only train line that they
have on the entire Island.
So that's why the taxis are like half the price that you get in Tokyo.
Yeah. If the, if the people rely on it, the local government will.
Yeah. Like a 30,
30 minute taxi ride in Oakland I was talking about was like 2000 yen. Oh.
Seriously. It's really, really Tokyo. That would be about like 60,
70 bucks.
Right? The in Tokyo, they don't, they don't make people retire.
They make them become tasks.
That's funny. Most times driver, when I see a young taxi driver, I'm like, wow,
you've made a career choice, career choice here. What's going on?
I speak to people. And they, like, I swear to God, they look,
they look at taxi drivers, like McDonald's walk is here. Like it's like,
it's it's uh, because yeah, because it's like,
you don't need any qualifications except drive, which, you know,
they expect you to do.
It's just like a throwaway job they make [inaudible]. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Basically. It's like,
I've I think the average age of a taxi driver here is like 70.
Like you're gonna retire.
Or will you retire or become a taxi driver?
It's like.
Taxi driver or like a construction worker, but not actually construction.
Just like holding the signs and paint like this way, please.
It's nuts. How fast they build houses here. It's like crazy.
We had like a whole school be built right next to the apartment I'm living in,
in the span of the year I was living here, which is insane. They built a full,
like three story house next to me. And like two months.
I was like, what the? What the? This is crazy. Like,
especially like say when you go into like the city or whatever,
and you haven't been for maybe like a couple of months,
it's surprising the amount of things that have changed being like, Oh,
this building was completely different two months ago.
And now this is magically here.